there have been so many great Disney
Channel original movies like The
Descendants franchise and all those High
School Musical films but just because
it's made by Disney Channel doesn't mean
it will be successful some of these TV
movies are seriously overrated watch
until the very end to discover which
decom sequel failed to live up to the
hype of its three previous installments
you stole that was spider-man we can
totally understand why Disney wanted to
create a spin-off to the high school
musical series of films the first movie
was such a big hit back in 2006
of course the sequels weren't quite so
good there was High School Musical 2 in
2007 and High School Musical 3 senior
year in 2008 they weren't as well
received as the original but that's to
be expected however at least these
sequels featured many of the same actors
recasting is never a good look after all
but when they tried to make a movie
around just one of the characters in
2011 things fell apart shar-peis
fabulous adventure was sadly lacking
most of the original characters and cast
and it's a pretty tough ask for Ashley
Tisdale to hold up the entire movie on
her own unsurprisingly she wasn't able
to make this spinoff a smash hit the
movie follows Sharpay as she moves to
New York City but let's be honest we all
wanted Troy and Gabriella cameos the big
musical numbers weren't as strong as we
would have wanted and it was hard to
root for a character that wasn't the
best person in the original New York is
calling and this is one call that is not
going to voicemail we're sticking with
decom franchises for our next entry and
lining up the Cheetah Girls One world as
an overrated film we know that the
Disney Channel can deliver when it comes
to multiple movies with the same cast
you only have to look at descendants to
see how it's possible to successfully
make three movies about the same
characters but way before descendants
rocked our musical world there was the
Cheetah Girls in 2003 the original movie
gained many fans and they were eager to
see more of the dancing girl group in
subsequent movies that's thanks in no
small part to the star power behind the
movie Raven Symone the 2006 sequel
imaginatively titled the
girls to kept up the good work oh my
goodness we're sitting here in my
bedroom eating kung pao chicken it does
not get any more undiscovered than that
but when Disney brought out a third film
in the franchise things didn't pan out
so well the 2008 movie called the
Cheetah Girls one world made one major
change that was its downfall Raven
Symone wasn't in it also the timelines
just didn't work
the trio of High School Musical movies
came out one year after another however
the third installment of the Cheetah
Girls was released five years after the
original the core fanbase of the first
film had probably grown up and grown out
of watching Disney Channel Original
Movies stay tuned to discover which
decom franchise lucked out when it
reached number four in the series we've
covered decom franchises and
disappointing sequels and spin-offs so
now let's look at another way the Disney
Channel likes to make overrated movies
and that's with film reboots of popular
TV shows this is a risky business as the
original TV series has so many fans that
love it just the way it is and they can
get pretty annoyed when the formula they
know and love is messed with case in
point the Even Stevens movie this film
was meant to act as the finale to the
show so it's kind of a big deal with
expectations high many fans were left
seriously disappointed the movie uses
the strange premise that the family
discovers everything that's going wrong
on their supposed luxury vacation is
happening because they're actually on a
reality show that's a pretty odd finale
to a much-loved TV series and this
premise plus its location disconnects
the story from the rest of the series
it's probably not something Shia LaBeouf
and Christy Carlson Romano will feature
high up on their resumes Disney bosses
listen up fans don't tend to like it
when you mess with the finales of their
favorite shows
on the subject of strange film remakes
of much-loved TV shows we're moving on
to Kim Possible this animated sitcom was
seriously popular so popular in fact
that the show was renewed thanks to
audience demand but the 2019 live-action
film split fans down the middle many
found it to be a letdown it's a pretty
tall asked to get viewers on board when
you're mapping a cartoon world into the
real world
Disney feature films have been on a roll
with their live-action remakes of
animated features The Lion King Aladdin
and Mulan are just a few of the classic
Disney features that have been
transposed into live-action in recent
years but the movie remake of Kim
Possible had another difficult hurdle to
jump let's not forget that the original
cartoon series aired from 2002 to 2007
the live-action remake came out 12 years
afterward that's a pretty big gap many
of the original viewers would have moved
on from watching the Disney Channel the
movie version did at least include some
Easter eggs to the original series for
eagle-eyed fans to spot you to be on on
the subject of remakes we have to
include the 2018 version of Freaky
Friday in our list it's the story of a
mother and daughter who swap bodies and
have to live each other's lives the
original movie came out in 1976 and
started at Barbara Harris and Jodie
Foster it was remade in 2003 with
Lindsay Lohan and Jamie Lee Curtis and
that remake was a box-office hit but
let's get real does anyone really need a
third version of a movie it turns out we
really really don't the Disney Channel
decided to bring out a musical version
of the movie in 2018 starring relative
unknowns cosy Xul's door and heidi
blinken staff perhaps that's where
Disney fell down the previous two
versions featured big names we're all
four up-and-coming actors getting their
big breaks but it just didn't work out
this time do not tell me to shut it oh
no you are my mom
of course the Disney Channel loves
making musical movies and so it makes
sense that two singers were chosen to
star in the 2006 movie cow bells
real-life sisters Aly & AJ Michalka
played the lead roles in the TV film and
they'd already been rocking it as pop
duo Aly & AJ Aly was also Edition
Channel alum having gained fame for
playing the role of Keeley teslo in the
Disney Channel TV series Phil of the
future so it sure does sound like a
winning formula on paper in reality
however cowbells was just another take
on that well-worn spoiled rich girl
trope the real-life siblings played two
bratty sisters forced to work in their
father's dairy factory to learn how to
be responsible if you like stereotypes
then you might like this movie but
otherwise you might find it to skip
worthy you seem to have a very real
problem staying focused if you ever need
proof that a good film needs more than a
good cast let's take a look at frenemies
this 2012 teen drama starred many of the
Disney Channels superstars at the time
we're talking about shake it ups bella
thorne and zendaya and Stephanie Scott
from ant farm when you think about what
they've gone on to achieve you'd expect
this to be a powerhouse of a decomp but
while their acting was good the plot
failed to impress rather than focus on
actual real-world problems people face
in their day-to-day lives this movie
about friends becoming enemies becoming
friends again
focused on high school nonsense not only
were the three separate storylines
seriously low stakes but they were also
totally predictable and the end of the
movie features one of the most awkward
song and dance scenes that you'll ever
see I can't think straight when I'm
around you
sticking with the theme of bad movies
happening to good actors dad napped is
our next entry do you think that a
decomp starring Emily Osment would be
good after all she's Haley Joel Osment
younger sister so good acting runs in
the family
and she made a name for herself on the
Disney Channel as Hanna's best friend
Lily in Hannah Montana but she hit a
bump in the road with the 2009 Disney
Channel movie dad napped as did the
other Disney Channel stars who signed up
for this disappointing film on 3rd
popular Disney Channel actors that
starred in the movie include David Henry
from Wizards of Waverly Place and
Emily's Hannah Montana co-star Jason
Earles while the acting was okay it
didn't showcase the cast's many talents
it's certainly not a highlight on any of
their resumes many viewers felt like the
script was poorly written and that the
plot of the movie was forced
[Music]
2009 was quite the year for
disappointing decomps not only was dad
napped released that year but so was
hatching Pete a movie about a high
school mascot there must have been
something in the water that year as this
movie also features a Hannah Montana
alum in the shape of mitchel Musso she
plays a popular high school student
who's allergic to the mascots chicken
suit
so his shy friend Pete played by jason
dolley from core in the house steps into
the role instead the concept was pretty
strange to begin with and the movie was
quickly forgotten about this is one
Disney Channel original movie fans will
probably not be streaming on Disney Plus
Pete I was slippery like a like an oiled
up watermelon we're finishing with a
decom franchise that should have stopped
when the going was still good they say
the third time's a charm
but perhaps Disney should have heeded
that phrase it's 1998 movie
Halloweentown was a big hit and its
first two sequels were successful too in
2001 we got Halloween town to Calibre's
revenge and in 2004 we got the third
installment Halloween town hi just got
one question what are you all doing here
these three movies stucks the important
formula of featuring the original core
cast including Debbie Reynolds and
Kimberly J Brown but then things went
south and recasting is very much to
blame the fourth installment called
return to Halloweentown was released in
2006 Debbie Reynolds was back as Aggie
Cromwell but Marnie Piper wasn't played
by Kimberly J Brown the actor has spoken
about how she was disappointed for the
fans when she found out that her part
had been recast hey Disney bosses when
you gotta learn that you should not mess
with a format that works which of these
Disney Channel original movies did you
enjoy the least and which decom is your
all-time favorite let us know in the
comments below
we're expecting lots of descendants fans
and High School Musical devotees to come
right out and declare their allegiance
let's find out what movie is the most
popular decomp of all actually please
give us a big thumbs up and remember to
hit that subscribe button to be the
first to watch our latest videos thanks
for watching